auau Mexique, où les réfugiés
hahaïtiens sont traités avec
unun peu plus d'humanité
L Les nouvelles de Del Rio
sosont mauvaises. Ces familles
onont préféré ne pas risquer
lala traversée de peur d'êtrtre
exexpulsées vers Haïti.
E Et puis, de toute facon depus
hihier, il n'y a plus personne
sosous le pont international :
leles réfugiés ont soit
étété déportés, soit acceptés
lele temps d'étudidier leur dosr
d'd'immigration.
A À 31 ans, Ennel Germain a
ququitté le Chili il y a un mois
avavec sa femme et sa fille.
ENENNEL GERMAIN
- - Je suis arrivé ici par bus,
etet j'ai fait comme cinq jours
dadans la forêt.t. C'est 5000 $.
- - Son périple lui a coûtété
505000 dollars; c'est la somme
ququ'il a pu économiser aprèss
avavoir travaillé quatre ans das
leles champs au Chili.
- - Mon épouse, j'ai quatre ans
llà-b-bas, mon épouse n'a jamais
trtravaillé. Nous avions des
fafamilles à H Haïti, il nous ft
enenvoyer de l'argent à m mes
paparents, et ma femme aussi.
- - Alors ils ont décidé
dede quitter le Chili.
LaLa plupart ici envoient
lele peu d'argent qu'ils gagnent
àà l leurs familles en Haïti.
DEDENIS OCKAN
- - J'ai passé comme cinq ans...
- - Au Chili?
- - Au Chili, et après,s, je pee
enen Colombie, Panama, Costa Ri,
GuGuatemala... jusqu'à c ce que
j'j'arrive ici au Mexique.
- - Un périple dangereux pour
DeDenis Ockan et sa famille :
cecertains de leur compatriotes
y y sont morts. Tous sont prêtss
àà t tout pour ne pas retourner
enen Haïti.
- - La situation est vraiment
teterrible! Vraiment, vraiment
teterrible! Imaginez-vous
sisi on tue le président,
lele premier citoyen du pays,
ququi... le premier citoyen
dudu pays qui a la sécurité.
MoMoi, je n'ai pas la sécurité.
- - Ça va bien. On est brûlélés!
- - Malgré tout, on tente
dede garder le moral.
JeJessica Francois a quitté
lele Brésil, car elle n'avait ps
dede papier d'immigration.
" "Ça fait une semaine que
jeje suis ici, dit-elle, j'ai pr
d'd'aller aux États-Unis, car
ilils vont me déporter en Haïti.
IlIl n'y a pas de travail pour
nonous, la-bas, pas de présiden.
C'C'est difficile."
M Mais cet arrêt t à A Acuña
esest temporaire. Un conseiller
mumunicipale leur annonce
ququ'ils vont êtrtre envoyés das
d'd'autres villes du Mexique.
- - Ils nous disent que nous
dedevons retourner à T Tapachul.
EtEt pour retourner à T Tapachu,
popour nous, c'est très s compl.
C'C'est une mini-déportation
popour nous.
- - Le président mexicain lance
ququ'il ne veut pas que le Mexie
dedevienne un camp de migrants
etet demande l'aide des Nations
ununies.
A Aux États-Unis, ils affirment
ququ'ils sont débordés par
leles demandes d'asile.
" "Nous avons 5000 dossiers
àà t traiter", dit le sécrétaire
dede la Sécurité intérieure.
A Au Mexique, ballottés d'un cp
àà l l'autre, ces réfugiés
nene savent toujours pas
cece que l'avenir leur réserve.
I Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
R Radio-Canada, Acuña, Mexiqu